[Música]
momento de hablar de economía aquí en
directo américa edición nocturna me
acompaña en el estudio daniela blandón
daniela muy buenas noches comenzamos
hablando de los precios de los
alquileres en eeuu que han subido en
líneas generales pero sobre todo en las
grandes ciudades donde ya de por sí eran
bastante costosos así de santiago muy
buenas noches y vamos a dar un ejemplo
como es la ciudad de nueva york a medida
que expiran los contratos de
arrendamiento de la era de la pandemia
los inquilinos de la gran manzana
enfrentan una subida histórica en los
precios de alquiler nuestra corresponsal
mamá en sala conoció como los
neoyorquinos se enfrentan a estos
cambios en el mercado inmobiliario
katy se mudó a este mini apartamento en
junio no le quedó más remedio que salir
de su anterior casa porque le subieron
de manera desmedida el alquiler está en
la lista y firmé un contrato por 18
meses y me dijeron que sólo subiría un
8% pero cuando el contrato terminó en
mayo de este año lo habían subido un 65
por ciento a dos mil ochocientos dólares
colores el costo de las rentas en eeuu
ha estado aumentando al ritmo más rápido
que se ha visto en 40 años esto es un
salón todavía no he puesto el inmueble
por eso esta escritora acabó en un
apartamento tan estrecho
pero donde sólo paga dos mil dólares al
mes un precio inimaginable ahora mismo
manhattan con alquileres históricos que
superan los cinco mil dólares mensuales
el sol de oro y es un poco raro pero
puedo hacer un futuro aquí porque es
raro es un poco raro porque es una fila
de habitaciones y no tiene armarios
según los expertos la guerra en ucrania
el aumento de los tipos de interés y la
inflación han creado una gran
incertidumbre los estadounidenses ahora
prefieren alquilar en vez de comprar y
la demanda se ha duplicado y
eso contribuye a rentas super altas
porque hay un aumento de la demanda sin
que haya al mismo tiempo un aumento de
la oferta
no hay viviendas para todos después de
que las obras de construcción se
detuvieran por la pandemia por eso
embajadores de la vivienda asequible en
nueva york como gabriel han visto crecer
las aplicaciones cada vez son más las
familias con ingresos medios o bajos que
buscan la ayuda pública
como ellos
con el salario de miriam y su marido no
llega a los cinco mil dólares mensuales
era imposible encontrar una casa hasta
que ganaron este apartamento en la
lotería de vivienda de nueva york solo
pagan mil setenta dólares mensuales la
renta me permite darme el lujo de llegar
a fin de mes bien la situación es tan
extrema que el ayuntamiento está
esforzándose por promover este programa
pospandemia ha sido un impacto
significativo para las ciudades los
nuevos presos de departamento nuevo
building y esto siempre ha sido una
opción que he estado allí sólo necesita
que la gente centre y ese es el trabajo
de gabriel que personas como miriam o
katy conozcan sus opciones por lo menos
hasta que los precios empiecen a
estabilizarse algo que según muchos
expertos está a punto de ocurrir
y ya lo estábamos mencionando en el
bloque de noticias aquí en directo
américa los estudiantes de eeuu que
tienen créditos estudiantiles
recibieron muy buenas noticias el día de
hoy daniela si santiago fue una promesa
de campaña de joe bardem y es que todos
aquellos deudores que ganen menos de 125
mil dólares al año serán elegibles para
una condonación de préstamo de 10.000
dólares que dependiendo del caso puede
inclusive llegar hasta los 20 mil
dólares ahora veamos más de 43 millones
de personas tienen una deuda estudiantil
federal con un promedio de 37 mil
dólares por persona de ese total una
tercera parte debe menos de 10 mil
dólares y quedaría libre de su deuda por
lo menos a la otra mitad o la mitad de
este total cerca de 222 mil millones de
personas deben menos de 20 mil dólares
bailan también anunció una pausa o un
periodo de gracia en los pagos en lo que
resta del año los republicanos han
rechazado la medida asegurando que es
desproporcional también que mal
acostumbrada la gente a los auxilios
gubernamentales y que puede empeorar la
inflación porque pone dinero en los
bolsillos también dicen que es injusta
con las familias que pagan el estudio
completo de sus hijos y sin ayudas
daniela y seis meses llevamos ya de la
guerra no crean ya cuál ha sido el
efecto que ha tenido esta guerra en los
mercados internacionales ha sacudido los
mercados financieros es sin duda deja un
panorama económico bastante complejo en
el continente europeo por ejemplo se
esparció un temor de recesión a lo que
se sumó un aumento en los precios del
petróleo del trigo del maíz y del gas
natural de este total de commodities
sólo el último continúa con senda
alcista los precios del maíz y del trigo
también se dispararon aunque ya
revirtieron la tendencia millones de
toneladas de esos cereales quedaron
atrapadas en los puertos ucranianos y
hace unas semanas ya empezaron a
evacuarse también tenemos problemas de
inflación las cadenas de suministro
están represadas y el aumento de los
precios de energía y de alimentos así
como las tasas de interés se están
elevando en todo el mundo empeorando ya
un panorama que venía en la pandemia
finalmente el éxodo de marcas santiago
muchas grandes marcas occidentales
dejaron territorio ruso empresas como
nike coca-cola al kia y apoyo en algunas
de ellas muchas gracias daniela por esta
actualidad de las noticias destacadas
del mundo económico a continuación es
directo américa el debate